hi there it's the Coffman here today I
want to combine sort of two issues one
is that words especially verbs and nouns
and adjectives but all verbs can have
different forms and there's always an
issue especially when we talk about word
count of link or recounts the number of
words you know should we be talking
about individual words like each form of
the word or should we be talking about
word families in some way so that's one
issue and the other issue is the use of
and key or SRS systems versus more
emphasis on exposure reading listening
and so forth and the reason I'm talking
about that is because we received a
letter and link actually was addressed
to my son mark and this person was
saying that they had been using they've
been a heavy user of and key and but
then they discovered they were spending
ten times as much time on Anki review as
they were spending risk you know reading
and listening to the language so they
with link moved into more of a listening
reading mode but they still kept Anki
because you know if they came across a
word for example in Russian the verb is
Scott is to look for but I look is issue
so there he said docked and he couldn't
tell whether this was in fact a word
that he already knew so this person
would then create some kind of a drill
in a key to go through all the different
forms of a scotch
including issue but that still left him
with a lot of time spent with Anki which
took away from the time that he could
spend reading and listening so you know
I thought about this so then I I say
okay first of all everyone has their own
way of studying you know Anke has it's
it's enthusiastic followers and that's
fine so I'm only gonna talk about what I
do and how I proceed
the role of Anki versus exposure reading
and listening and this issue of
different forms of words so first of all
with regard to forms of words nowadays
the dictionaries that we can access
online are so good that if you see the
word issue you will see for example if
you use context reversal which is an
excellent dictionary you can see the
definition of issue you can see examples
of issue in use and you can see a full
conjugation table of that verb with the
one that you've saved here highlighted
so that you can immediately deal with
where that form of the word fits in it's
impossible to absorb that whole table
but if you keep on going back to it as
you come across different forms of the
verb and save different forms of the
verb as separate you know terms that you
say that link and on each occasion you
can look at the table slowly that is
helping you start to recognize the
different forms and the fact that they
all come together so I think even if you
don't use an anchor deck just focusing
on listening and reading and then
referring to the dictionary and then
referring to these tables every time you
come across a different form of boom of
a word or a noun
I think that can be quite effective so I
think there are ways that you can deal
with this issue a second question that
comes up is often linked why do we count
them as separate words when they're part
of the same essentially the same word I
mean the extreme example is car and cars
or in the case of Arabic we're a plural
always has a what in front of it so
you're getting a two for one because you
see it as
around the initial time then you see a
war plus the noun and you get credit for
that as a known word my view and that is
it doesn't really matter the known word
total is simply a milestone indicating
you are progressing in the language it's
a little bit motivating I have often
sort of referred to it as the mechanical
rabbit that the dogs in the dog races
chase so every time I get on link I see
where I am in my profile how many words
I know and I'm motivated to increase
that so even if the numbers are little
inflated if my desire to chase that non
words total is getting me to read more
and more and listen more and more then
that's a good thing so that the main
role of this known work total is not so
that you can brag to people but that
this hopefully motivates you to consume
more material to spend more time
listening and reading because I think
that you shouldn't be spending ten times
as much time reviewing words as you are
exposing yourself to new material where
you will find new words and at the same
time encounter some of the words that
you have previously say and which are
now highlighted in yellow and linked and
also there's a practical problem too in
that you know again I only have so much
time to spend on language learning the
biggest sort of type of activity the
most important activity is listening
because I can do it yesterday you know
we had my son mark was visiting with his
wife here in Palm Springs I'm talking
with the airport so on my way back
that's 35 minutes I'm listening to
Arabic so it's so easy to organize the
listening part but of course if you
listen you have to understand what
you're listening to and therefore that
gets you to read it so now you have to
read it and when you read it their words
you don't know so you look them up and
save them and then they're highlighted
in yellow so that this is spurring you
to more exposure I do occasionally
review the sort of flashcard activities
after each lesson but if I were to spend
a lot of time reviewing these in an
antitype situation I wouldn't have much
time left for listening and reading so
if I look at my statistics for example
in Arabic at this point I have created
4700 links that is that means that I
have saved 4700 terms that I've
encountered in my listening and reading
I have 2000 onwards whatever that means
I'm encouraged
I mean motivated to get it up to 3,000
because I've announced that when I get
to 3,000 onwards I'm going to start
trying to speak to people I have read
20,000 words and that's only the first
time I read them because I have reread
many of these stories so I actually have
read much more than that so that's a lot
of time and my listening and this is
quite accurate now because I do my
listening either you know listening to
the lesson as I study the lesson or on a
playlist while I'm you know driving my
car as I said so I have listened 90
hours that's an awful lot of time so I
don't know that I have a lot of time
left over to spend on Anki just out of
curiosity I went back to my week
learning and I spent you know more than
six months on Greek and there I read
200,000 words at least to the extent of
their track that link and there I had
created 27,000 links that I had I had
saved twenty-seven thousand words and
phrases you know what I have had time to
review them in and key I doubt it and
I'd be interested to hear from people
how they managed to juggle and key
review with lots of listening and
reading of the 27,000 links of I created
I ended up learning 6,000 that means
that 6,000 of those 20,000 were
converted to known but I heard I didn't
do a lot of flashcard review but when I
see these in mind in my reading then I
have a chance to move the status of
- no so that those 6,000 words I would
have seen again and again and then moved
them to known at some point but my total
known word number was 9000 so presumably
there were a lot of forms of words that
I felt I didn't need to save now because
I knew what they meant based on being
having been exposed to other words that
were similar to them maybe other you
know forms of the verb or whatever it
might be in Greek so again what I have
been further ahead with an anchored on
would I have exposed myself to 200,000
words of reading what I don't know I
don't have my listening stats here but
it's gonna be more than the 90 hours
because none 90 hours of Arabic is after
three months so I can assume that it's
well over it might be 200 hours of
listening and Greek would I have done
that if I had been spending that much
time on thank you I don't know so
obviously the SRS algorithms are helpful
but it is only a form of exposure and I
have had the experience that sometimes
the things that I learned through
deliberate learning using flashcards or
whatever method where now I think I know
it somehow later on I don't know it
again and to some extent I guess the SRS
algorithm is supposed to bring it back
to you at a point in time where
theoretically you haven't yet forgotten
it but that doesn't guarantee that you
won't forget it again and I would rather
be motivated to continue to meet these
words in context and along the way
expose myself to all these other words
that I've been learning in a natural
living context whether I'm listening or
reading because ultimately it's my view
that the learning of the language not
just the words but even the
pronunciation and that sense of the
language and above all listening
comprehension which is such an important
skill all of that comes from natural
exposure to meaningful context listening
in reading so whatever you do in sort of
deliberate learning deliberate reading
of grammar books deliberate study of
flashcards it does help but it is it is
not as effective if you have limited
time as exposing yourself to the
language so I guess to some extent the
strategy that one adopts aside from
personal preferences will depend on how
much time you have to spend and in my
case if I can get in a half hour to an
hour of listening every day and add a
little bit of reading and maybe 5-10
minutes of flashcard review that seems
to optimize my time but I accept that
different people have different
circumstances different things they like
to do so I'm sure I'll get some pushback
from staunch and it's not to challenge
the energy users but it's meant merely
to indicate that this is how I learn so
all thought was interesting and useful
bye for now
[Music]